AACR ongoing commitment to the growth and support of
pathologists who are engaged in cancer research worldwide.
This year, we are honored to present this distinguished award
to Dr. David Rim, the Anthony N.
Brady Professor of Pathology and Professor of Medicine,
Director of Yale Cancer Center Tissue Microarray Facility, and the
Director of Yale Pathology Tissue Service
at Yale School of Medicine. Dr. Rim is an
exceptional scientist and pathologist whose
innovations in quantitative biomarker science have
transformed cancer diagnosis and informed modern
approaches to precision medicine.
His work has pushed the boundaries of how we
measure, interpret, and clinically apply
biomarkers in human tissue.
A central focus of Dr. Rim's career has been
the development of rigorous quantitative methods for
tissue biomarker research. In early studies of
prognostic biomarkers in breast cancer, he identified
a challenge, the lack of accurate and
reproducible tools to quantify predictive
biomarkers in tissue specimens. To address this,
he invented the EquAsystem in 2002,
a groundbreaking fluorescent-based platform
for automated quantitative analysis.
This innovation revolutionized immunohistochemistry,
establishing a new benchmark for precision,
and enabling the widespread adoption of quantitative
pathology.
Building on this work, Dr. Rim became an early
leader in the use of tissue microarray, and his
laboratory developed imaging
pipelines for hotspot identification and quantitative
analysis.
These advances enabled essential studies into biomarker
heterogeneity, including the clinical significance of
EGFR and estrogen receptor variability in breast
cancer.
More recently, Dr. Rim has applied his biomarker
expertise to cancer immunotherapy.
His
investigations into the prognostic and predictive role of
PD-L1 expression across breast cancer,
melanoma, and lung cancer demonstrated that
PD-L1 alone is insufficient as a biomarker
unless evaluated in the context of specific immune cell
subsets and their spatial relationship to tumor
cells. This insight has shaped modern approaches to
immunotherapy biomarker assessment.
Dr. Rim's contribution to biomarker science
have had a profound impact. He
has played a central role in national and international efforts
to establish guidelines for biomarker evaluation,
particularly for HER2, ER, and PR in
breast cancer, directly improving diagnostic
accuracy and patient care worldwide.
Dr. Rim has been a dedicated AACR member
since 2002, and his leadership,
scholarship, and innovation have left an
indelible mark in the field of pathology and on cancer
research as a whole.
It is my great honor to introduce the
2026 recipient of the AACR
James S. Ewing–Thelma B. Dunn Award for
Outstanding Achievement in Pathology in Cancer Research,
Dr. David Rim.
Thanks, Dr. Kapoor, for that very flattering introduction.
I have a lot to live up to now. And thanks also for
the committee for selecting me. I had to read the email multiple times.
I was so surprised that I was actually the selection this year.
What I want to do, though, is nicely summarized in your introduction, that is, talk
about
the underlying concept of how we
quantify pathology and how we make it reproducible,
as opposed to what we
mostly have in pathology today. I want to just show my disclosures first
and note that a lot of the work that I do is sponsored by biotech or
pharma because we have mutual interests.
Although some of it is sponsored by NCI as well.
Today, in the next 30 minutes or so, I want to talk about Dr. Ewing and Dr.
Dunn and their contribution to anatomic pathology just briefly.
But then I want to talk about spatial analysis of histology, because that's the
heart of what pathology really is.
And then
talk about measuring and what we've done, what we've contributed to the field in
measurement, and what we've done more recently in terms of
bringing standardization to measurement, which I think is something I should have
thought of 20 years ago, but here we are today just now standardizing it.
Then finally, I'll talk about the newest concept we're working on in my lab, and
the idea that
there needs to be a biomarker that selects between drugs.
Not just a companion diagnostic for a single drug, but a biomarker that
selects between drugs that are both eligible for treating a patient in the
same clinical setting.
So, this is Dr. Ewing.
He graduated in 1897 and was the first
professor of clinical pathology at Medical
College of Cornell University, and he was one of the founding members
of AACR back in 1907. And I think that
probably what
has led to hison the named award. The
other perhaps most significant contribution is the Ewing sarcoma.
It was originally called the diffuse endothelioma of bone,
and published, but now known as Ewing sarcoma, which we all learn in our first or
second year of pathology residency.
And it's a tough one, but we'll get back to that in a minute.
And then he was featured on the cover of Time magazine, perhaps the only
pathologist ever to be on the cover of Time magazine,
and then ultimately retired in 1939.
But the award is not just named for Dr. Ewing, it's also named for Dr. Dunn.
Dr. Dunn had an interesting career as well.
She got her MD in 1926 before women got
MDs. She was one of the only women in her class to get an MD.
Ultimately, became an assistant professor at UVA, but then a
year later, married William Dunn and took his last name.
And so this award is named the Ewing Thelma Brumfield Dunn
Award.
And then the most interesting part, perhaps, of her career is what doesn't
happen now. That is, she moved to Washington and took a six-year hiatus to
raise three children. I'm proud to say that probably half of my graduate
students have had children while they're in the lab completing their thesis.
That's how it should be.
We shouldn't have to see a hiatus in
careers in order for women to
excel.
In the end, she was a clinical instructor, ultimately led a fellow at the
NCI, where she led a lot of laboratory mouse work,
and in fact, that was her claim to fame was to sort of really opening up the
field of using mouse models in research.
And then she was a staff pathologist, published classifications of tumors,
and ultimately the first woman president of AACR, which has landed her
as a name on this award, which I'm very proud to
have received.
So what about spatial analysis? Let's move on to that next.
Spatial analysis is the basis of anatomic pathology, and I like to use this
illustration. This is all the information of color
in a Monet and a Renoir, but the only thing that's missing is the spatial
information. So here is the intensity scale, and then this is the blue, the
green, and the red that make up these two masterpieces.
Does anyone want to speculate on which is which?
So sometimes there's an art history major in the audience that says, "Oh, a lot of
light blue. This one must be the Monet." And they're right.
But I've yet to have an audience that can tell me this is "The Boating Party" and
this is "The Stroll." And that's because of the two-dimensional information.
And that's why what we do as pathologists is so important.
In fact, it's integration of that two-dimensional information into a final
diagnosis and into patterns and into classifications
that really is what pathology's all about.
The rest of the world finally recognized that in 2024 when spatial proteomics
or spatial biology was declared the method of the year.
But it's funny that it took
2024 before it was called the method of the year, because we've been
doing spatial analysis since Ewing and even before then,
when we looked at two-dimensional
tissue slides. And here it is. So here's the spatial analysis of the Ewing
sarcoma. And you can see this is a hard one.
There's not a lot of distinguishing features to compare to some spatial analysis of
some tumor types. But you can see this list of bullet points of
how we, as pathologists, try to define Ewing sarcoma, and now more
recently, how we can define it from a molecular alteration.
And this is important, too, because I think that what we're seeing now is the
evolution from spatial information to spatial plus molecular
information, and I think that that's what--
And by far, the most contribution for spatial information
or molecular information has been from genomic work, DNA
assessment. But I would argue that protein is equally important.
Actually, protein is closer to function.
And so we've focused, in my career, on measuring protein.
Speaking of measuring,
I like to define two different terms as we start out.
Reading is what pathologists do. It's the subjective but expert
interpretation of information on the histology slide.
Whereas measuring is a quantitative, objective determination of amounts or
concentrations of protein or signal on a histopathology slide.
And it's sort of been my mission over my career to move from reading to measuring.
So can we do it without any special molecular tools?
Well, yes. Now with all the AI and image analysis
tools, we can actually start to measure.
And this is an example of segmentation measuring lymphocytes.
Let's see if that's going to work or not.
Measuring lymphocytes and tumor cells by spatial information and
segmentation alone.
However, it doesn't always work so well. Look at this one.
Here, half of the cells that are lymphocytes are considered to be tumor cells,
and probably vice versa. So measurement still has a little ways to go.
Now, this is a pretty primitive segmentation tool, and it's getting better and
better, as you can see that a multi-pass segmentation
tool
from Janice Taub and Alex Salehi has improved cell segmentation dramatically.
And then there are other software algorithms that have improved
segmentation by using not just cells, but other entities.
But finally, I would argue that it's still a challenge to segment things that are
not easily segmented, like this. So if you
imagine taking a section through here, you wouldn't just see round items with
a nucleus. You'd see little sections of lymphocyte, and if you hit this
one toward the North Pole, you might not see a nucleus.
And so those represent some of the challenges of segmentation that are now actually
being addressed pretty well
by
AI. This is just to show another example of a hard-to-segment case, and
time will tell if we can segment this,
where you have a
single tentacle of a cell or a dendrite reaching down into other
epithelial cells.And this is what we've done so far, and this is actually a
poster that's being shown right now where we try to calculate
something quantitative, in this case TILS or tumor-infiltrating lymphocytes,
and take an image that's not been molecularly treated in any way other
than the H&E, hematoxylin and eosin, and make a quantitative result
out of it. Now, we're just scratching the surface in my lab.
This is work that we did in collaboration with Anat Matoubushi, looking at all the
different ways you can quantify the H&E.
And in fact, the number and mechanisms of ways of quantification of the
H&E using artificial intelligence and image analysis
are shocking. And one wonders as the session
before that I attended before this one was
determining the expression profile and transcriptomics based on the
H&E. Can they really do that? Well, time will tell, but there's a lot of people
talking at this very meeting about looking at being able to determine which
RNAs are expressed from the H&E alone.
Time will tell, but it's certainly more quantitative than
just looking at it and giving a subjective read.
So let's talk about measuring, because what we can measure and what
I've spent my career doing is trying to measure protein.
So this is where it all started. This guy is Clive Taylor, and the story goes that
Clive-- and this is sort of the timeline of protein
assessment. And in 1974, Clive Taylor took
an immunofluorescent image of a tissue slide to
his mentor, David Mason, and said, "So what do you think?"
And David said, "This is great, but I can't see the tumor surrounding the
interesting expression pattern.
Can you do something about that?" And so he went back into the lab
and
generated a chromogenic method that is a way that blocked light so that you could
counter-stain with hematoxylin.
And that result gave images that look like this, where
there's the H&E, and then if it's positive for the protein that you're trying to
assess, like p63 in the case of this squamous cell carcinoma, it's dark
brown. And if it's negative, you don't see any brown at all.
And so this is what the assay was designed for, was using it for a selective or
diagnostic assay in order to figure out what the tumor's expressing.
So in this case, if it's TTF1 positive, it's an adenocarcinoma, and
p63 positive, it's a squamous cell carcinoma.
And that
binary choice of diagnosis is what
the chromogenic method that Clive Taylor
invented was really designed for.
Since then, we've pushed the method to places that probably it shouldn't go,
and that is making it quantitative or semi-quantitative.
Semi-quantitative because of scores.
And when I started as a resident, I was told immunohistochemistry would never be
quantitative. It would only ever be semi-quantitative.
And pretty much that's right with the tools that we use for standard
immunohistochemistry. That is, chromogens have great limitations as a tool for
measurement.
And you can see that there's not only the problem of the intensity of
the chromogen, but the intensity of the background hematoxylin.
And all these variables make it difficult to measure an immunohistochemistry
slide.
To verify this, this is actually the fifth edition.
The sixth edition is now out, but I got a kick out of this.
There's 944 pages, nine of which are on quantitative information.
And the sixth edition is no better or worse, that is, that
quantitative aspects of immunohistochemistry are not considered to be that
important for pathologists.
But I want to focus on that. And this was a
binary marker made for HER2 to give or not give trastuzumab,
probably the most important drug in breast cancer in our generation.
And if it looked like this, that was 3 plus, those were positive, and the rest of
them were negative. And so if it looked like this, you did some other tricks.
You did in situ hybridization to
determine whether or not it was actually an amplified gene or not.
But these are probably all gene amplified, and these are not.
But now we're asked to tell the difference between zero and one.
This is something that pathologists have no business doing, but we're asked to
do that, in fact, required to do that in order to prescribe a
drug. If the patient's going to get trastuzumab deruxtecan, they have to have at
least a zero plus or originally a one plus, not a zero
in order to get that. Can we do that?
Well, here's the new task, and here's how we've done on it so far.
This is work from Jack Robinson in our lab done a few years back, where
we gave 18 different pathologists 170 cases and said, "Just score it according
to the ASCO/CAP guidelines." We didn't tell them we were going to look at the
difference between zero and one, but we told them, "Just score it according to the
ASCO/CAP guidelines. Let's see how you do." And what you see is that pathologist
number one, 44% of the patients were not qualified for
trastuzumab deruxtecan, but on those same slides, pathologist number
18 only disqualified 15%. So that means whether or not you
got a drug depended on who your pathologist was, not the
biology of your tumor.
Was it just us? No. Since then, there's been a number of other studies.
Here's a study in Japan with 144 pathologists reading 20 cases.
Their overall agreement was 63%, a little better than we had.
And then in Australia, nine pathologists did 60 cases with an
overall agreement of 80%. And probably the best sort of
ring study was done by Joe Rusoff and colleagues, actually 77
pathologists, mostly from European countries.
And what they found is that to agree on zero, they
use the term overall rater agreement and not even using
pathologists, raters, which is technically the right way to do a
comparison study like this. And you can see that their overall rater agreement
was 83% or 82%
for 4b5, which is HER2 by the standard
FDA-approved assay.
Interestingly, they thought that maybe we could train this, and in fact, you
can't train it. You can see no statistically significant increase with
training pathologists on how to read HER2 low.
Also interesting is we're really good at HER2 high.
If it's HER2 amplified, we're going to get that right, and that's because that's
what the assay was designed for. And so in some ways, it's no surprise.
So maybe80% is good enough and
95% is good enough, or 98% to 99% is good enough if it's
amplified. Or is it? So let's compare it to some other
modalities. Here's what we do for lung cancer.
We look at for EGFR mutations, and this was a study from over 10 years ago,
where they looked for EGFR mutations in the same specimen in a number of
different labs. And here's how they agreed.
Here's the number of cases and then their percent agreement on these
cases. So overall, the average reproducibility was
99%. That's what we should offer our patients.
So until we get there with protein, I will still be working on this topic.
I really think that it's possible, and back when we started, back when
Marissa was in the lab,
it was probably impossible. I'm not sure we had the technology then.
We tried, but we didn't have it standardized, and that was a long time ago.
Now, the computer power has become so strong and so
much more
storage for so little
money that I think we really can be rigorously quantitative.
Although, probably we shouldn't use the standard methods of
immunohistochemistry. We should probably use immunofluorescence.
So how do we measure on a slide?
So we talked about reading. That's pathologist-based scoring, and I told you some
of that. And if you want to measure, you can actually circle the region of interest
and then just measure the intensity of chromagen and sum all the pixels together,
and you can do that. That's a pretty primitive way of measuring, but it does
actually work, and it was one of the earliest ways that people measured
immunohistochemistry. Then there's segment and phenotype and count.
This is what the most common thing is, and this is still what a lot of automatic
software does is that first it segments.
That means it finds all the single cells, and then it phenotypes them with
some biomarker, and then it counts how many are positive and how many are
negative. The problem with this is that in
order to have the software work, you need to have a threshold.
That is, it has to be decided that a cell is either positive or negative,
and then you can count the cells that are positive or count the cells that are
negative. But that's not how biology works.
Biology is continuous information.
And so if you want to
actually get an accurate measurement, I think we'll never get away with
segmenting and counting. I think we're going to have to have some other method,
and that's what we invented all those years ago, which was not
just looking at the segmentation but actually using the area.
This is just an example of segmenting and counting and the flaw with it.
So if your threshold is 15% gray, then you have 50%
positive. But if your threshold was 5% gray, you'd have
70% positive. So which is it? Well, hard to say.
So we invented an H-score so we could combine those things so we'd have
both a score and sort of a pseudo-continuous score.
But in fact, if it was a dark day, that is if your stainer wasn't working a
little bit the same way it did the day before, you might change your score from
145 to 160 with just a 10% change in the
intensity of the stain. So does that happen? Well, actually it does.
This is from David Dobbs and Steve Bogan, who used bead standards
and looked at the limits of detection.
In these assays, this group of dots, each of these dots represents a
CLIA lab. That is a certified lab using a standard
Ventana stainer, Roche stainer, using the actual
instructions in the box. And you can see that there's a threefold
difference in the lowest in one lab compared to that top lab.
And that's just the way it is. It's really hard to fix that.
And Bogan et al. proposed using some sort of standardization
method to fix it. But even though these are auto stainers, there's at least a
factor of three difference from day to day or week to week.
And that makes chromagens not the right reagent for doing quantification.
So, this is just to sort of estimate how right we are or how
wrong we are. And so we had 17 pathologists do
percentage of cells positive, and we calculated the coefficient of
variation. Coefficient of variation tells you your reproducibility and your
precision. And you can see that on average for Trop-2 H
scores with five pathologists, the range of CV was from zero to 75,
depending on the score itself. But the average was
20%.
Shockingly, the average was over 80% for immune cells,
which means that I think that you need to not use an H score
because a coefficient of variation of 80% is not tolerable for
patients. The FDA asks us to get a coefficient of variation
of 10% or less for approvals.
So this is why you shouldn't use chromagens. How many pennies?
How many light bulbs? Well, if we summed up the information of the
intensity of the light bulbs, we could figure that out.
I don't have that done for you. But if we summed up the information of the pennies,
we would come up with five when it's actually 100.
And that's because chromagens don't transmit light. It's physics.
You can't break the laws of physics.
And so I think that this is why I've moved from chromagens
early in my career to fluorescence because you can sum the intensity.
And even when three bulbs are on top of each other, the sum intensity is pretty
much accurate compared to the intensity of looking at how much light is
blocked.
So this is what we invented back in the day.
And I need to mention Bob Camp, who was really pivotal in this
invention that we called AQUA for automated quantitative analysis.
First, we called it Tiresias, but I won't go there.
The concept behind it was to sum the intensity of the
target within a compartment divided by the area, so you
could make something like a concentration.
And so we took a mask, that's where the tumor was, and then we'd sum the intensity,
in this case of estrogen receptor, across that area, and you'd have
ultimately a score initially, but more recently in attomoles per
square millimeter. So how do we get to attomoles per square millimeter?
So it's the same concept, but this is done more recently and just published two
years ago with Jack Robbins, a graduate student in my lab.
And what he didwas figure out how to do immunofluorescence and then
deposit fluorophores, but not just on the tumor of interest and the slide of
interest, but also on a bunch of cell lines.
So these cell lines were produced and then arrayed by our
colleagues. And each of these cell lines was also grown separately and frozen
down so we could determine the attomoles of cell lines per microgram
of total protein. Then we could convert that by figuring out the area
of each cell and calculating the area of each cell so
that for each cell line, we can have an attomoles per square millimeter of
HER2. And while we were at it, we did Trop-2 as well in attomoles per
square millimeter. Then you can, just like in college biochemistry, you can figure
out the intensity of your signal and go back down and figure out your attomoles per
square millimeter. And that's what we've done, and that's how we
can get to absolute quantification of fluorescence
as opposed to quantification of chromagens or immunohistochemistry.
Ultimately, we found out probably we're going to have to use percentiles because
the absolute number of attomoles is not the best way to compare them.
But we'll talk about that a little later on.
This is what this assay we now call the Troplex Assay since it does
Trop-2 and HER2. And this is how it works in the CLIA lab.
When the recuts come to the QDAP lab, that stands for Quantitative Diagnostics and
Anatomic Pathology. And the QIF stainer is
done on a Leica Bond, and there's one control slide, or a CMA, is a control
microarray, for each nine patient slides.
And you can see there's three rows in these Leica Bond stainers. So one per tray.
And then the biopsy is scanned, and the attomoles is calculated for the
entire specimen. Then the
software written by Jack converts the
fluorescent image to an H&E or to what looks like a DAB image or a
chromagenic image. And if you can see, this is what it actually looks like.
This looks pretty much like a DAB chromagen that looks so much like
a chromagen that I can circle the region of interest so we're sure we're not
measuring normal ducts, or we're not measuring stroma down here, and we're only
measuring the concentration of HER2 and Trop-2 in the actual tumor.
Now I showed you this high power because you can see how heterogeneous it is.
And those who want to criticize the fact that this doesn't deal with heterogeneity
are 100% right. But we got to walk before we run.
Someday we'll figure out heterogeneity.
But for now, we average everything within the circle performed by the pathologist.
The result of that looks something like this.
This was 316 cases prospectively collected at Yale
from the Yale Surgical Pathology Suite.
So these are actual breast cancer cases, and they're colored by their actual
IHC score that was given to the patient on the basis of which the patient was given
a drug. If you measure them, you can see we did pretty well.
They got trastuzumab if they were red or orange, and those are mostly up here on
the high end. But down at the low end, where they may or may
not get trastuzumab deruxtecan or in the future, other
HER2 low drugs, you can see that the blues and the greens, the zeros and ones
are essentially interchangeable.
And so that means that we don't have the ability to, by eye,
distinguish low from very low. And in fact, interestingly,
because it's a quantitative assay, we can calculate a limit of detection
and a limit of quantification. And you can see actually that about 5
or 6% of the cases are even below our limit of detection.
Those are probably the true negatives, and those probably patients shouldn't get
T-DXd, whereas all the rest of them might have enough T-DXd to
benefit. LOQ is a limit of quantification, but we don't know what the limit is
yet. And we're working very hard on figuring out what the threshold is for
a response to trastuzumab deruxtecan.
This is also just showing the same thing on a second study where
we did Trop-2 at the same time that we did HER2 on about 160 cases
and saw pretty much the same thing.
But if you do two markers at the same time, you can do a
scatter plot. And so you can look at the relationship between the markers.
And this is the relationship between those markers on the 160 case prospective
trial. And you can see there's almost an inverse relationship.
That is, if you have high HER2, you're pretty low for Trop-2 and vice versa.
If you have high Trop-2, you're generally on the lower side for HER2.
And so even though it's not a true inverse relationship and occasionally there's
positives for both, I think that it's probably important that
this information is used to select which drug the patient gets first,
since both the trastuzumab deruxtecan and
SG or dato-DXd drugs are
approved in the same
advanced breast cancer metastatic setting.
What was the
CV of this assay? So we calculated the CV, both inter-assay and
intra-assay precision, and both were calculated as less than
10%. And the reason for that is because we have a cell line standard that we
can use. If you don't have a way to standardize your assay, you're not going to get
a low CV. And I think this is a critical piece of what we've
done.
The assay is now available, and this is the splash sheet from our
clinical lab.
But I point this out because one of the things we tried to do was meet the
standards of New York State Department of Health, which is kind of
FDA light. And we've actually done that.
It's FDA, it's New York State Department of Health approved assay, which
was quite an effort, but I think gives a credential
of being accurate and precise.
The prospective study is published in "Laboratory
Investigation" led by Nai Chen,
and the study on the Troplex assay itself is
published in "JCO Precision Oncology" led by Jack Robins.
So that was nice, Dave, but how did these do? Does it make any difference?
Well, so we checked, and we're still in the process of checking that.
I'll tell you, there are at least six trials going on now, two
of which or three of which are prospective.
And so what I'm going to show you is just the retrospective older ones.
This was actually presented at ESMO almost two years ago now.
And it was 51 cases collected by our colleagues at Dana-Farber Cancer
Institute.And what they found is that when you split by quartiles
as a function of the atom moles per square millimeter, it was statistically
significant and in fact, the patients with the highest did the best, and the
patients with the lowest did the worst.
In fact, what they found, since it's a continuous units, they could look at the
unit increase and found statistically significant for every 50 unit
increase, there was a hazard ratio of 0.7, which was statistically significant.
We've done our own study, and this is work led by Jack Robbins in the lab,
where we've collected cases of patients treated with T-DXd in the second-line
metastatic setting or higher from Yale, and this is the distribution, and then used
the Tropix assay. And here's what it looked like.
Again, what you see is most of the three pluses were up here, but there's an
occasional one plus or even a zero that has quite a bit more.
And then some of the lows are pretty low, but there's some two pluses down pretty
low as well. So it doesn't agree totally with what the pathologist
called at the time of the metastatic specimen staining.
What we saw was that when we cut at the median, this is preliminary data with only
65 cases, so we only cut at the median, and what we saw is a difference
between 12.8 months for the high group and 7.5 months for the low
group.
When we did-- This is a little peek into the study that's just finished.
Jack hasn't finished analyzing yet, but it's 150 cases, so a little
more robust, more than twice the number.
And interestingly, we pretty much get this as time to next treatment.
This is overall survival and pretty much get the same thing.
That is that I'm reassured that the fact that we can get
high levels or a high reproducibility when we more than double our
cohort size really suggests that probably the amount of
target that's expressed is closely related to the likelihood of response.
This is an interesting finding that we're not sure how to explain yet, but I'll
share with you even though we don't know what's going on.
And that is if you have high Trop-2 in that same cohort that are given
T-DXd, you do poorly.
These patients that had high Trop-2 did worse than the patients that
had low Trop-2. This is below the median. This is above the median.
So probably an artifact of a small cohort, right? Well, actually not.
We saw it again with our 150 case cohort.
And here's overall survival. And what you can see is that if patients that
have really high, the top quartile of Trop-2, probably you
shouldn't give them T-DXd. Now, time will tell if this really bears out.
And I don't know of the biological relationship yet. We're looking at that.
But whether it's time to next treatment or overall survival, you pretty much see
the same thing. And what happens if you use both? Well, this was interesting.
If you're high for HER2 and low for Trop-2, or low for
HER2 and low for Trop-2, those are the two rightmost colors, the blue
and the orange. But if you're high for Trop-2, the red and the green,
pretty much you're not going to benefit from T-DXd regardless of whether
or not you're high or low for HER2.
And so, okay, 65 cases. Come on, give me a break.
Okay, well, it validated. Here's 150 cases, and it still seems to be
the case that you need to be probably high for HER2 and
low for Trop-2 in order to really benefit.
And the others were still too small to really distinguish the
others. But it still has a similar appearance that the patients that are
high for HER2 and high for Trop-2 tend to not do as
well because of the high Trop-2.
Hopefully, this will ultimately be wrapped
up by our biostatistical group and published in the next three to six months,
optimistically.
So what about SG? We can also use this and look at Trop-2, and this
is work done by Ming He in my lab, and she looked at 67
cases collected from the pathology archives, all who are treated with SG,
sacituzumab govitecan, in the second-line or higher setting of metastatic breast
cancer. Here's the representation of the cases that we
saw, and all cases were analyzed with the same
Tropix assay.
And what you saw was this, that if you cut by quartiles, you don't really see
much. But if you take the bottom quartile and look at the top three,
which you can make an argument groups here, then it is statistically significant.
And the patients with really low Trop-2 probably shouldn't get SG.
They're probably going to do worse if they get SG than the patients with higher
Trop-2. It's interestingly that when you look at the top three quartiles, we can't
really split them apart. Now maybe that's because our cohort is too small, and
certainly, in the ASCENT trial, there's some evidence that the more Trop-2 you
have, the better you do. But in today's study,
this is where we stand.
This is the
forest plot of that same data, and you can see high versus low Trop-2 is one of
the only thing that other than prior ADCs, one of the only
statistically significant findings.
So that was measuring protein. And in the last five minutes, I want to talk about
the concept of, I think, what's coming next, and that is selective markers.
So we have these biomarkers, diagnostic, prognostic, and
predictive biomarkers, and we all know all about those, and I won't spend
time going over those because we're short on time.
But I think we need a fourth category now that I'm calling a selective biomarker.
And you can argue we've already done this.
And when you do a panel of 400 genes, you're selecting between which gene
mutation is appropriate for the lung cancer patient or will drive
which drug that the lung cancer patient is given.
But I think now we need to do it for protein as well.
And I would argue that especially in breast cancer, as we get more and more
indications in the advanced setting, we had to decide
which drug to choose when there are multiple choices in that setting.
And ultimately, the best way to do that, I think, use the tumor biology as
opposed to the pathologist opinion.
So this is just the tip of the iceberg.
I said there's 260 known antigens being clinically tested for
antibody drug conjugates. But then someone who spoke before me in my talk on
Friday said, "No, there's 400." So it's a lot either way.
There's a lot of ADCs being tested, which increases the likelihood that we're going
to need a selective assay.And so here's what I talked about before,
where you have an almost inverse relationship, but this is, I think, the kind of
argument you need for a selective assay.
That if you're high for one and low for the other, that should be what drives
the
prescription of which drug you get first
in the metastatic setting or advanced breast cancer setting.
Is it just
HER2, or is it just breast cancer? No, this is actually trastuzumab
versus
enfortumab vedotin, or nectin-4 versus HER2 in
the setting of bladder cancer. And this is a bunch of bladder cancer cases.
This is only a TMA study. But you can see the same thing.
That is, there's some cases that are low for nectin-4 but high for
HER2. They should probably get T-DXd first, whereas there's some cases that are low
for HER2 and high for nectin-4, and those should
probably be the patients that get enfortumab vedotin
first.
We're close to being there with a nectin-4 quantitative assay.
And here's our pipeline at the QDAP Lab.
HER2 is out. Trop-2, we've done. Troplex, we've done.
Nectin-4, probably will have this year.
We're very close to having that quantified in animals per square millimeter, as we
are for HER3 and cMet. Might be optimistic for
2026. But FolR1 is also moving along quickly for the
GYN space. And what our real vision is, is that you pick three and you
plug them in and you can have any three of these markers, depending on
the clinical setting that's appropriate for those markers.
Should we have 10 instead of three?
Well, maybe someday, but we need to walk before we run.
And we started with two. In fact, initially, we may do pairwise
assays because from the time we get them working in the lab to the time we get it
working in the CLIA lab, there's still quite a bit of effort that goes into that
CLIA lab validation. And so,
we might start by having only duplex assays as opposed to
triplex. But this is what our vision is.
So with that, I'd like to thank all the people in the lab that actually do the
work, and this is my current lab group, and a lot of collaborators outside
my group, and especially lab alums, which I'll mention in a second.
And
some collaborators outside Yale, including Paolo and Sarah, and
Regan Fulton, who makes all our cell line arrays at Array Science.
This is our lab at our last holiday party, and this is our lab website.
But since this is an award lectureship, I want to go a little further and
give a few more credits. And so one of the things I want to do that I think is
really important for any junior people in the lab is to get the right mentor.
And boy, did I get the right mentors. Here they are.
This guy is why I do quantitative stuff.
As my PhD mentor, Tom said, "If you can't measure it, it doesn't mean anything."
And so he was the stimulation for all of the measurement
part that I got into pathology. This guy, John Morrow, was my postdoc mentor,
and he taught me how to write. If I couldn't write grants well like John does,
I probably wouldn't have been so successful and been so well-funded.
And then these other people that I show here are mentors that had various impacts
on my career, even though I didn't actually study as a trainee with
them. Jack Fravel was my mentor for my cytopathology fellowship.
Joe Madri was a mentor throughout my career for rigorous science.
Larry True taught me about how to translate what you're doing in your research lab
to a clinical lab. And Dan Hayes taught me about oncology and the
importance of levels of evidence.
Finally, I need to thank my mentees. There's a lot of them.
These are all the people that have worked in my lab since I started in 1994
until this year. And I really think that I was blessed to
have such a smart and
hardworking group of people that decided that they wanted to spend some time in my
group. And
I would be done except for one last thing, my family.
And I wanted to particularly thank my two
children for putting up with me during all the time when my career was building,
Daniel and Rachel. And now Daniel's married to Jess, so I have a daughter-in-law.
And then the most important person to thank is sitting right there.
Janet is my wife, and she supported me throughout my whole career.
Thank you.
So with that, I think I can take questions.
We actually probably don't have much time for questions. Maybe one or two.
Thank you, doctor. And that was a wonderful talk.
Thank you, and congratulations once again.
Thank you.
If anyone has questions, there are two mics.
Please introduce yourself-
Yes
... and then ask the question. Thank you.
Yes.
Miles Brown, Dana-Farber. Hi, David. Great talk.
Thanks, Miles.
So when you saw this
effect of Trop-2 in HER2 activities, so do
you control for intrinsic subtypes?
So what I wonder is whether what you really are revealing the
differential expression by intrinsic subtype.
Well, so
how do you define subtypes? Because a quarter or maybe as many
as three-quarters of the triple negatives actually express HER2.
Sure.
So they're not-
Okay. So by RNA defined intrinsic subtypes.
Right.
But we don't do that. We didn't do RNA in all of them.
We only have their subtypes by IHC. That's a great question, though.
When we looked at the scatter plots by estrogen receptor status, which is probably
pretty accurate, there was no trend.
Phil Dennis, NovaBridge. I noticed in your pipeline, claudin 18.2 isn't
there, and there's a lot of controversy about measuring 18.2 using
IHC, and I'm just curious if it's just-
It's further back, but it's in the pipeline.
Okay.
I just didn't show it. I do think that's another important biomarker that we
should investigate.
Max Fodor. I just wanted to say thanks. That was a really great talk.
Thank you.
Just a question that we've discussed many times, but pre-analytical variables,
can we standardize those or can we go beyond those to
standardize?
So the pre-analytic variables, I think, have been addressed
mostly by the core biopsy. If you only look at core biopsies and if your
surgeons or radiologists are all instructed to take the core biopsy and put
it right in formalin, there's very little pre-analytic time for warm ischemia or
cold ischemia. And those are really highly reproducible.
In fact, years ago, we studied the phosphorylation status of
those markers, and even very labile
phosphorylations that disappear in 15 minutes and-On the
benchtop are still preserved in core biopsies.
So I would argue that pre-analytic variables are a problem that we need to deal
with, and the way we deal with it is by
instructing our tissue collectors to be sure they fix it in formalin
as quickly as they can.
Hi, Chris Weickert from Keck University. Very nice talk.
One question, how do we design clinical trials in the future,
and how do we find the correct cutoff value?
So that's a great question. As what is the cutoff?
And I would even go so further as, is there a cutoff?
And as there might be multiple mechanisms of action for antibody drug
conjugates. So there may not be a cutoff, but we have two clinical trials
going to look for a cutoff. One's called QUANTIFY-HER, which is run by the
Translational Breast Cancer Research Consortium, and another one is our own
retrospective study, which I hope to have shown you, but we're not quite
done with to look and see if we can find a cutoff.
In preliminary data, it looks like there's not one.
That is, occasionally you see a responder even when they have almost no HER2
at all.
Thank you very much.
One of my star mentees, Kurt.
Yeah, no, I have two. First, I want to thank you as a mentee and in the
name of most of your mentees here,
for all the
tenacity and optimism which is critical in this job, as you know very well.
Second, as a colleague, now I'm in the same department, and we're so lucky
to have you and to inspire everyone.
And third, I have actually a question
and it's related with this
sort of obsession to measure things in the membrane, that we have seen
over and over for years with very little data.
So,
what do you think about that? Should we actually spend the time and energy trying
to resolve the measurement of these targets in the membrane?
I think we have learned that may not be the case. What do you think about that?
So that's a great question, Kurt, and one of my other mentees, Mark
Gustafson, sitting in the audience, would argue we really need to look beyond the
membrane, and we need to look in the cytoplasm and who knows, maybe even in the
nucleus. And I have a student who's currently working
with confocal images to compare treated patients
that are stained with HER2 in the traditional way.
They're all trastuzumab treated.
And we hope that with confocal we can unwind the amount of membranous versus
non-membranous staining and its contribution to response to trastuzumab.
Thank you. And one last question. As a tumor immunologist, I think
ADCs are immunotherapy. I'm sure about that.
It's an antibody, it's there.
What do you think is the contribution of the tumor microenvironment and engagement
of adaptive immunity in duration of response?
Do you think there is a role there, something to look at?
So, absolutely. And I think that
when we first learned about ADCs, we thought there should be a threshold below
which if you don't have the target, you don't respond.
And I would state probably the target is half to three-quarters of the
story, but the immune system is probably the other half or the other
three-quarters, and time will tell.
It's been very hard to tease that out, and especially since we're all so
laser-focused on the target itself because of the nature of the drug.
Thank you.
Thanks for those questions.
I have one last question. Among all the different
technologies that you have helped bring forward, which of the
one you feel has been most impactful for patient care and
which you are most proud of?
So, the technology of measuring protein with a
quantitative fluorescence tool with standardization is what I'm most proud
of. And I would say that, and I've heard many times, "Dave, that's nice,
but if you can do it in your little lab, how does that get to the patient?" And
the answer to that question is we're now negotiating.
So Yale owns it, obviously, because I work at Yale, but we're now
negotiating with Yale with three different companies who might commercialize it.
Because if it can't get commercialized, it will never get beyond my little
lab. But that's the technology of which I'm most proud.
Wonderful.
Thank you.
Thank you so much, and thank you, everyone.
Thank you so much.